interesting applications so take it away
okay great um thank you very much for
your
uh yes thank you very much for the
invitation um it's my honor to speak
here
um okay so today i'll talk about
directed graphical models for extreme
value statistics so this is joint work
with
johannes bach who's a phd student uh and
claudia
cooper book who's her uh who's his uh
advisor at the technical university of
munich
okay so first i have a question for you
um uh
so i i'll give you two problems okay and
i'll ask you which one you think is
easier
okay so problem one um you have
a uh river network let's say in this
case the danube
um and i i sample you know
uh i have 31 stations on the danube um
and i record uh the daily flow of of the
river
okay uh but i'm not going to give you
the daily recording
i'm going to give you only the maxima
uh of every week okay um so so the data
is
is a lot less compared to daily or
hourly recording okay
and your jobs and i don't tell you how i
don't tell you any more
information about the stations uh or the
river
your goal is given this uh this maxima
recording
um can you recover the river network
okay so that's problem one uh problem
two on the right here
is you have a binary
relu network just two layers um
and so your job is to recover this this
uh this
uh relu network right so the weights
here are
there there are a sort of bias term
they're real numbers
um the only tourist here is that you
don't get to see the input
okay so you only get to see noisy
outputs
okay so um all right so so you get the
outputs and then you know it's add on to
noise but if you can solve the problem
you know the output problem without
noise it's already pretty good okay
so which problem do you think is easier
recovering the network
from a bunch of extreme flows or uh
recovering a
binary relu network but only from the
outputs
i would guess the the river network
because i know really not learning value
networks is hard
okay so if we have some experts here who
said yeah relu seems pretty hard so this
one would just be easier
okay um great so it turns out that they
are
essentially the same problems right so
that's part of the point of this talk
is that if you consult one problem then
you'll be able to solve the other right
uh and in particular this case turns out
is a
easy instance of the right hand side
which tells you that the right-hand side
also has some easy instances that you
can solve right and indeed
um it's just if i just give you this
without the noise
right just seeing the output i don't
tell you what the inputs are
uh i don't and and if i ask you how many
input notes are there uh that's already
uh
kind of amply complete to to recover the
number of input nodes correctly
um so this is a result in 2014 by
sheetal
okay all right so why why these problems
well they're not toy problems they're
very important
so this hidden river problem is the
benchmark for causal inference in
extreme value statistics
it picked up a lot of steam especially
with the danube as the benchmark data
set
um starting with this paper in sort of
the analyst to probability in 2015
and then followed by a bunch of paper in
in statistics okay
now it's really it's defined like the
fancier version of this problem is what
people in hydrology really want to solve
which is
uh i have a waterway uh say like this
map
right and uh i have uh
sensors at various locations uh and i'm
tracking not the water flow but some
contaminants so think some chemicals
or it could be a chloride concentration
or
you know some kind of bacteria in the
water okay um
so if you if you do continuous recording
then you get to see
you know graphs like this right so um
you know uh
the the sensor will record at regular
times and then you see this this curves
and your goal is given these graphs um
recover
uh you know where if you see a
contaminant uh
spike somewhere say here um something
happening at b
you want to to trace back uh where is
the source of this contamination okay
uh this is a sorry i didn't i didn't
totally follow that are you going to
define the problem more formally or
would you mind just saying a few more
words about what the formal problem is
yes i'll tell you what what the formal
problem is this is just uh yes
so here's the here's the formula okay
right thanks um
no problem uh so uh right so if if
you're
uh just want to use like a vanilla
bayesian network uh you can
right so you can formalize the problem
like this i have a graph g
uh on d notes um and i will put an edge
i to j
means node i is directly upstream from
node j okay so i have some graph
i i don't get to see this graph right
and what i get to measure are just you
know measurements
x i uh contamination concentration
at node i and now here is my modal
choice right i could if i
decide that i have i put in
a linear model then the model would say
contaminant concentration at node i
is a linear combination of uh its
its you know ancestors right plus
uh zi which is what you think of as a
random input source at i
right so contamination at i could be uh
what you get
from your parents plus potentially you
know somebody's just dumped like a
massive amount of contaminants here
so that's or could be from a storm or
you know extra sources you don't know
uh that's your input to to the system gi
okay
um can i can i just think can i just
think of the zi as iid gaussian or
no right so so zi
no so zi you want to think of them as
iid but from an extreme value
distribution
like uh like a gumball okay that's right
okay uh yes is it uh is it easy to see
that this identifiable
is it easy to see that uh so yes so
it's it's a like it depends you have to
put some function on b uh some some
um some functions some some assumptions
on b for sure
yes this this i wanted to say i i'm
about to say this is not quite the right
model
but this would be like the the basic
model that if you didn't do any extreme
value theory then this
is the first one you would start with
okay i just want to start with something
familiar yes
okay any other questions
okay great all right um yes so if you do
a linear model then this is how it looks
like
and you can rearrange this equation um
you know you
you write in matrix form right uh you
throw the b on the other side take the
inverse assuming the inverse exists
right and then you get
x as purely as the linear combination of
the sources
at the at the ancestors okay so your
goal is given these
measurement exercise you want to to
recover g
from from noisy samples okay so this is
very classical
um you know linear like if you believe
the zi's are gaussian then you just get
a plane you know
vanilla gaussian invasions um
you can uh you know we restricted the
case where
it's okay to for nice river you you it's
okay to say the river is a directed
acyclic
graph or even better uh the river is a
tree
right so for example the case of the
danube then then it is indeed
a tree okay so so then for these cases
there are many techniques to recover
um uh yeah so sorry i was in a mad rush
to prepare this slide so i didn't
list all the names but including you
know are many people in the audience who
have worked on
uh techniques for learning uh uh
bayesian networks from data right so
there's scorebase right constraint based
hybrid methods
uh if you're a tree then it's fairly
easy you just
you just score each edge and then you
you find the best
um uh sort of the maximum directed tree
that maximize the total score
with the with the sort of truly admin
algorithm right
so all right so we just for a moment you
don't forget anything about extreme
values you know
just apply a vanilla uh model uh with
averages
um does it work right um
so you know so given this extreme the
title probably you would guess
not right so i'll just remind you the
linear model is like this
now the problem with this data uh the
the actual
you know river contaminant data
is that contact contaminants can only be
detected
above a certain threshold right so
so actually you don't really what you're
observing is not
averages but it's just the upper
quantile
of a certain distribution right so you
you you need a model that can deal with
maxima
uh instead of averages right the other
issue is that
um it this seems to be like a fault of
the sensors like if you fix the sensor
you can record at all instances
but that's not true because by design
some contaminants are only released
through
uh storm events right so there's a lot
of um
bad chemicals in uh our daily lives like
from the roof from the car
on the road and whatnot and when there's
a big storm
then then all of these get washed uh uh
uh washed off the road and it enters the
waterway
right so that's the only time that you
get to see those contaminants
and they usually come in massive
quantity so you have a very sensitive
sensor sitting there
then most of the time it's going to take
zero and then with a storm it will
detect a massive amount right so that's
just
by design um you're not measuring
averages with maxima
and also because if you're waiting for
these storm events uh
you know naturally also if you're
looking maxima you have few and noisy
data
right so this is a recurrent theme in
extreme value statistics you have a few
data
you're dealing with maxima and and it's
fairly noisy
so so really the the question you want
to know is if i have a big value uh
at a node uh if if i is honestly an
upstream node from j right if there's a
big value
x i then you would expect to see a big
value in xj right so you want to look at
sort of tail dependence of random
variables
uh and and that's that's the theme of
cause or inferential extremes okay
um yes so i guess the the most important
thing is
you know i'm dealing with maxima i have
few and have noisy data
any questions
okay great
all right um so now let me go back to
the problem
of relu with binary weight right so
here's a proposition
it stated a little bit sloppily because
um
to quantify this part uh you know
it's not difficult but it just takes a
lot more unraveling
um so roughly speaking if you face a
problem like this with extreme
measurements on a river network
what you can do is you can take the
logarithm coordinate wise
and then classical results from extreme
value theory will tell you
this log of x is well approximated
by a relu with binary weights
okay and these sources are unknown okay
so that is x tilde i right it's going to
max over j
of c i j plus uh an an
input uh ztoj which you which you don't
get to observe
right so this is the only thing you get
to observe the number of p's this is the
number of inputs
is also unknown and also uh the
obviously the values of the inputs are
unknown right
okay um okay so the proof is not
difficult
um so it comes from basically two key
results in extreme value theory
right number one said that um
uh well you know before taking log then
this is just a
you know x i is it it's called max
linear factor model so x
i is the max over j of b i j times
z j okay and now uh
sort of classical result in in extreme
value said
that if you have if you look at a maxima
of iid
right then uh that
then you then normalize maximum app id
converges
in distribution um if and only if
the limit is a max stable distribution
okay
so you think about this as like um like
saying that max stable distributions
are the gaussian analog for extremes
right so for you know for classical
statistics you know if you have
sum of ids you take averages right then
then you're under
nice variance conditions you can reach
the gaussian right so here
if you take normalized maxima id then it
has to converge to something called a
max table
right and now the second result is
you know emerged later after people know
more about different representations of
max tables
right so this is you can find it for
example in a paper by stoif
and tayaku in 2005. they just said
that max level distribution any
multivariate maximal distribution
can be approximated arbitrarily well by
max linear models
right so the how well this approximation
is is
uh is well you know the higher p is then
you know the better you can
the more coefficients you have to choose
and so the finer the approximation will
be
right but uh so so this max factor
linear model is really
a discrete a discrete approximation of a
max stable distribution
right so together right this said that
if you have
data where you believe that your data
are just
a kind of maxima of independent
instances
right then you can approximate it with a
take the log then you can approximate it
with a value
with binary weights okay all right okay
so uh so that's nice uh that does
that just tell you the problem's hard
right uh so your goal is to find the cij
uh but you only get to observe the
the the outputs okay
um right so i i just mentioned that this
problem
specifically in this form not in the
relu form but in this form it has been
studied in the tropical literature
so this is called the tropical
non-negative matrix factorization
it also has a name people also called
tropical pca
uh and people prove that it's it's
difficult right they're they're
algorithms that
you know designed to work in the general
case uh but
the with noise they don't perform you
know amazing
right okay um
so now uh right so
uh so now a max linear model will have p
inputs and d outputs so is there an
instance where we can solve this problem
right so the general problem is hard but
if you happen to know that p
is equal to d uh then this problem is
is easy right well it's it's solvable
it's very solvable
so this is uh sort of the main theme
so this is again another classical
result from tropical linear algebra
uh it's just a manipulation of this of
this
equation right so if i have p is equals
to d
right then then my matrix c is is a
you know it's a d by d matrix right um
and suppose that d is a part supported
on a directed a sticky graph
right so the entries of of c are in r
except when i don't have an
edge then i have an entry of negative
infinity okay
so yeah so if that's the case then i can
rewrite this equation
not x as the function of z uh but
x as a function of x right i can rewrite
as like a recurrent uh
uh kind of a a recurrent network
right so the point of this rewriting
right is that first of all this is
honestly a
a bayesian network right uh in the sense
that you know the random variable x
you know is a its distribution x i is a
function of its parents
right um but also um you know this is
probably the best you can do right when
it comes to binary
relu which is if you only get to observe
the outputs right then
what you want to look for is some kind
of um
you know is you want to exploit the fact
uh that
there's there's this this uh the output
of a relu
uh is piecewise linear so you basically
want to detect where
it is where the boundaries are right and
and and for that you have to figure out
uh for each you know tilde x i right uh
what are some linear relations uh it
must satisfy uh
relative to to other uh soda xj okay
so that's like the the best thing that
you could do right so
um okay so if p goes to d then we have
uh
this kind of uh rewriting right
and so now uh all it takes is to figure
out
uh does it make sense to assume uh in
the river problem
that i have p equals to d right um so
uh so this basically means uh well that
means the number of input is the same as
the number of outputs
right which means that sort of for each
source
for each node i uh i have kind of a a
source
uh zi right and and these sources are
are independent
right so um so if you translate to
hydrology term it basically means
that your stations they're far apart so
that when there is a
a an external source uh that get
detected at node
i right so if there is a some somebody
a massive amount of chemicals at station
i uh then you don't expect
that to you know then the only way that
you expect to see those chemicals
is because from i uh uh that chemical
flow downstream and then get detected on
node j right you don't
get some other i prime that get the same
nump
of chemicals okay so this is okay if
your stations are far apart if your
stations are really close together
then one storm event could could create
some uh some
you know we could mess this
assumption up okay all right okay
so uh so so all of that tells us that
here's our problem
right my goal is um i have a dac g
on it i have a matrix c right supported
on on g
i i'm given a few and noisy observations
from this model
right and my goal is to learn the dac
okay okay so again here
uh this is a kind of bayesian network
it's non-linear uh i have few and noisy
observations
uh but you know i can still apply you
know one of the
two strategies for learning equation
networks right one is to
to figure out in conditional
independence constraints
right so i compute from data you know
from this model
what are all the possible conditional
independence constraints and then i find
a best that g right the the problem with
this
is that max linear vision networks uh
they have a different condition
conditional independence theory from the
classical one right so classical
independent conditional independence
is characterized by d separation so
so d separation is characterized
classical conditional independence
on you know on just usual basic networks
right
but because here i have such a special
form
a special sub family of bayesian
networks
that it turns out i have a different
conditional independence theory right
and so
we made a step on this but we haven't
really figured out for example how to
compute
such constraints from data so it's it's
still very much
uh there's a lot of open questions uh to
to
to to generalize constraint based
methods to to
vaccinate abrasion networks um now the
other alternative
is to look at score based so i i want to
find a graph that optimizes score right
um
well the most common score is a
likelihood but you know if you have few
noisy data and if the data come from
extreme right so this max
is a very bad uh operator uh
you know likelihood of maxima is is is
very
uh it's very it is intractable uh you
you can't optimize it beyond dimension
three
right so so that's not so great right so
you just need a different kind of score
okay um right uh and also
anything you propose have to be
computable
okay um so uh
so what we did so i should say we have
proposed one score
um and it's very much still open as to
what's a better score
right so there's some suspect suspicion
that mutual information or or some
version of you know
sort of conditional entropy would work
well uh i would love to see
uh sort of more more research in that
direction okay um
so what we did was we separate the issue
into two parts right i have
noisy and i have few data so first uh
what if i had a noise free but few data
is learning possible
right so it turns out in this case it's
not difficult right so
if i'm noise free then i just rewrite
this equation
right so if i have x i minus x j is is
well you know x i x still i is is a max
of this so it's bigger than you know c
star i j
plus x j right so if i rearrange then i
have x i
minus x j is bigger than equal to c star
aj
right so so once again that tells me
that this coefficient here
is just a a lower bound for x i minus x
j
right and in fact whenever an edge you
know uh j
really you know if a flat j really
causes a flat that i
then i actually have an equality that is
you know x tilt at j
is equal to c star i j uh
sorry x still at i is equal to c star i
j plus x j
right so that means that this equality
for noise-free data
i expect this equality to be attained
right at some samples
points right if i have enough samples
right so that tells me
that this distribution of pairs if i
just look at
pairs of of notes right if i honestly
have an edge from j to i
then i expect that this the distribution
of this random variable
has an atom at this minimum right so
here you see like a simulation
of this uh phenomenon right so
uh here in this graph i have three uh
points to two points to one
right so in particular you know i i also
three is also a one is also uh
reachable uh from three okay so the red
uh uh points are the simulated data from
the noise free
model right and and the green points are
uh
uh kind of you know uh this model with
with gaussian noise right
so it's it's yes so it is important to
notice that
i have two uh so my model is
uh max j before i rewrite it like this
then it's c
i j plus z zj right so these are the
sources
which i don't think of them as noise i
think of them as input to my you know
relu
and then on top of this i have uh noise
epsilon i
these are like noise due to measurement
noise right
so so the measurement noise is gaussian
but the sources may not be gaussians
okay okay so if this distribution has an
atom at the minimum
then i can basically uh well i can
detect it by a simple histogram right
if i have perfect data if i don't have
perfect data
then how likely is there an edge from j
to i
it's really a question of how
concentrated my distribution is
near the minimum right so so it's not
the value of the minimum that matters
is the question of do i see
concentration there to believe that
there there could be an
atom at this distribution right so
there are many measures of concentration
uh but if you balance out you know
whether it's computable
so for example variance of the k of the
minimum order statistic works great
on paper but if you want to compute such
a thing
uh it's it's you need a huge amount of
data um
so if if you want something that's
that's fairly crude uh but
can can be computed from data then you
can settle for example
for the quantity gap right so the
quantity gap is basically the gap
between two quantiles
um you can take for example the the gap
between the
the let's say the the fifth quantile and
uh some something like the uh let's say
the 20th right so so that would be uh
the absolute value of that would give
you an idea
of how concentrated your your
observations are you're the minimum
okay i have a quick question um is it
clear that you can always attribute this
to
one specific edge i mean what if you
have multiple things that have the same
value
if you have the multiple things
uh
do do you mean like if you have a
situation like
this right or a whole separate
uh line of inputs going to three
from elsewhere and then is it clear you
could you'd be able to attribute this to
two or maybe
four instead
oh right um so yes good
great question so that's it it's not
true when you when you take
uh averages right but it's uh it's
generally okay because i have a
maximum so the max operator is it's sort
of it's like a winner take call
situation right so the
if if i um so the model set right that
x i is the max in this case like x3
basically is the max of um uh
you know c 3 2 plus x 2
c 3 4 plus x 4 c35 plus x5
and c31 plus x1 right so that's
x3 is the max of this three right so
then you know if the multiple of those
could be the same
yes but right so multiple of those could
be the same only
if your uh distribution uh the the the
source distribution
z um has atoms right because
so this was a rewriting from this model
here
right this is the original model right
um
right where where each note i has as a
has a z
i that that's the that's the thing
that's driving all this
uh once you have the input zi then the x
when you observe is just the max of the
z
guys right so now if the distribution of
zi
is continuous um then you don't expect
this max to to be
achieved at multiple points yes right
okay sure perfect thank you
yeah yeah thank you yeah but i mean if
it's discrete then definitely things go
crazy
um right but i should say like for
example
in this graph already if this max is
is achieved at three at
one right so that means you know if one
uh
the flood at one was what caused the
flood of three
then if i have a tree then anything
along this path would also achieve this
maximum as well
right uh because if i want to flood from
one to propagate down to three
then it has to go to two right um and
and and that's okay right because
um um so so when you're computing this
concentration
uh when you compute this score then what
matter
is that you would have a highest score
for
for the edge one two three but what you
want is that the score for the edge one
two three
in general you want it to be uh uh
smaller than the score
from the edge from two to three right um
so this is saying that uh you know it's
okay that sometimes flat from
one can cause flutter three but you know
generally speaking you expect that
flutter too
uh you know flooding at two
uh causes flooding at three uh more
often than you know
uh flood from one calling causing
flooding at three right and this is
truly true if you have no noise right
because
uh yeah because what i just said that
flood from one must travel to two
before it goes to three um but if you
have noise then you know you want that
this has to be true in expectation
okay and that that's sort of part of our
proof of consistency that this indeed
check out if you have uh sort of a
continuous distribution
for the sources yeah great great
question thank you
okay um right so then our algorithm
is just for each score for each edge i'm
just going to score it independently
right i just by you know computing the
quantity gap between x
i and the quantity depth of x
i minus 6 j um and then afterwards i
apply
you know i if i assume it's a tree then
i just apply a
uh edmonds algorithm to find the maximum
uh uh directed sort of spanning tree
okay
so because all of the computation just
come from you know
computing for each pair it is a local
competition so it's it's very efficient
right so you can um uh you can uh
we we have a theorem that quantify like
what is efficiency means
and it's a is a is an if and only if
kind of theorem um
that said if you have you know not
enough observations then
you have unidentifiability issues and if
you have enough observations to make the
model identifiable
uh then you know with high probability
our
our estimator will be correct assuming
that there's no noise right
okay so right so that's the issue with
few data so now
um uh you need to deal with the noise
um and if you don't it won't work very
well uh so i have some graphs later on
that shows that
now where does the noise really come
from
right so so the noise comes from the
fact that my model
the max linear model is an approximation
to the maximum of iid
right so so improving this there was a
proposition that i said oh i can
use this model and there was two parts
right number one
was that you know normalize
iid conversion distribution to max table
and then number two is that i can
approximate max table
uh with uh max linear
right okay so it's the first part
that's that's kind of that that's not
that approximation you know it's like
saying you approximate
the the the sample mean with with
gaussians well you know you need
certain properties for that for that to
work well right
so if you look at how data is processed
so this is by for example
uh this is really uh standard so this is
from
uh the paper by assadi in 2015
right so they were processing the data
from the danube right
so uh what they did was they set a
threshold about point nine
right so any um for for each node right
you only look at
observations that are you know uh in the
90th quantile and above
right um but now uh if you detect
an extreme observation here at this time
window then they took like a seven day
window around it
um and then uh they look at all the
other nodes and then they just take the
maxima
uh over that seven day window
of at the other node right so now this
maxima
may or may not clear the clear the
ninety percent threshold
for that node itself okay so here in
this example if i have this this one's
node one three and four right
so note one right was what triggered the
seven day window
uh so i detected a flood on note one i
looked at over a period of seven days
and i looked and i found that oh no
three also clear the threshold node four
also cleared the threshold but not two
didn't
right note two uh didn't experience you
know a flood
um but i have to record you know some
values right so what i end up
is i record the big the largest value
for note 2
over the seven day period right so what
this means
is and this is very intuitive right this
is saying if i have a flood
you know if i have a flat here then this
flood is going to propagate downstream
so i see flooding at two i see flooding
on one but you know
measurements at other nodes uh is
basically
they're just they're not flooding right
but so they're just maxima
but but but they're not big enough to
really
sit in this max stable regime right so
they're big measurements but they're not
big enough
uh for the approximation with max table
to work well right
um whereas my model right
my daughter then just wrongly insists
that the the data is extreme at all
coordinates right
so that's that's a very serious problem
um there isn't really a good
uh well okay i should say i i don't know
of a good solutions uh
so the the trick uh from extreme value
is
uh well then you know if you when you're
doing this local computation
to score an edge from j to i if i only
need to look
at the quantile of the distribution x i
minus x j
um i don't have to use all of my data i
can only i i it is enough to just
look at uh cases where uh
xj is really big right so i basically
take for each whenever i consider
a a a h a potential edge let's say
3 to 14 right then i look at
uh the subset of the data where uh
where x3 was honestly big right that
there was honestly a flood at note 3
and and then i can try to see if that
creates a concentration downstairs
but this is a i find this at least for
statistic it works okay
but for um from a modeling viewpoint uh
this is very
uh kind of annoying it will be nicer if
we have a model that account for this
fact
uh but currently we don't right and so
it's sort of an open problem
to to really deal with this uh in at the
level of the model and not
kind of half horizontally uh halfway
through uh with the estimator
okay what the upshot is that we get
pretty good results right so
um on the left here is this no tears um
learning algorithm uh so this is a a
very recent paper
uh by zhang aragam ravi kumar and singh
so they give an algorithm to to sort of
learn
uh a directed acyclic graph
uh they can fit linear and non-linear
models
uh and they turn it into a continuous
optimization problem like i like this
paper a lot
and i mean for the danube it works
pretty well
right so on this is the result of this
is their result
uh this is our result um blue is correct
edges
right red is sort of wrong direction
and green is a correct direction but
it's not
it is it's not a correct edge right in
the sense that
i have a uh a green edge is
or green or yellow is an edge that goes
from a grandparent to
to to to a child right as opposed to
uh going from uh the parent directly to
the child
right so you see uh so rats are really
bad right so
there's a few wrong directions uh but
not too many right so we also get a few
wrong directions
we even had like a worse kind of arrow
that that puts like the the wrong route
to the tree
um but yeah so overall is honestly it's
comparable right
so that's the case with the den loop and
this is really surprising right because
i just been telling you
that you know extreme values everything
has to be extreme uh and now here i'm
just fitting
a a a linear uh bayesian networks
that is you know the kind where x i is
just the sum
of c i j uh x j right so this is just
i'm just taking averages i'm treating
the extreme data as if it was average
and i still get decent results right but
this is a property of the
of the more than it's a property of the
method right so
here uh if i run the same thing on a
different river
this is the the lower colorado the one
that runs through austin
so on the left uh is their results uh
which
well we didn't type it up uh because
it's not very good right so you see
there's a lot of
red edges right on the right is al's
method and on the far right
is the true river right so if you look
at the true river
uh all these black edges here um so we
got like a few of these
wrong skips right uh but very few right
overall
we managed to recover uh the the river
uh
pretty well right um yeah
so what's the what's the sort of
international property of
the uh uh of the colorado river that
it's better yes exactly so that's that's
what i i i would tell you next
right um so um let me maybe
i would skip this two and i'll just jump
straight to here so
what is the difference between the
danube and the and the lower colorado
and is there a theory that can explain
it right um
so we think that um so we have an
intuitive explanation uh we conjecture
something right
that i think can be made mathematically
precise but but i don't have a proof
okay so i i would love to have uh an
open quencher
uh uh so i i would love to have an
explanation okay
um so uh what happens if you just look
at the data set
colorado right if you just look at the
data set then loop is very nice
right at any station at any time you
have a number that's not zero right
that's not the case with the colorado um
the colorado
is um is you know if you just zoom in to
the part of colorado it's like this
right there there's a lot of branches of
the colorado that suffer from drought
right so you see here this bunch of
stations that just measure zero there's
sponge that are missing
right the sensors just fail and it takes
like a couple of days for it to be
recovered
um and then there's like massive
fluctuations right so
so what happened with the lower colorado
you get the the average
regime and the extreme regimes differ
widely right so in average on average
you you're in drought
right so a lot of the stations on the
average is zero gives you
zero information about you know what
happens to the flood
and then you get a massive flash flood
which lasts for not too long
so some floods the floods have to be big
enough before it can
propagate downstairs uh to to other
nodes right so it's not enough that you
flood
you have to flood a massive amount
before you can you know jump to the next
node right so it's a very hostile kind
of data set
you have drought flash flood fail
sensors misting data you have dams that
sort of cut the river into three parts
uh it but
it's very much like real real
contaminant data right so
so any method i i think method should be
really benchmark on the colorado and not
so much on the done
right the danube is really nice right
and why
well if it's nice then um the link
between
an average uh sort of gaussian model
and the extreme is given by this result
right so this is a classical
result from textbook uh here's one
possible reference
right and what is said is that if i have
a just a plain classical linear
factor model and if my my sources
are heavy tail distributions and and my
measurement noise is light tail right um
then uh then if you look at the tail
dependence function
which is a measure of you know if x i is
big does it imply
that you know x j is big right that's
what we want to measure
the tail dependence function of these
two models are the same right tail
dependence function of a
sort of a heavy tail uh linear model
and a maxi linear model are the same
right so what this means
is that if the danube is a is a river
that can really be modeled uh by this
uh linear model right um then
um well then sort of the average flow
you can recover the the river from
average flow
right and and the the mo the noise that
you're getting
from the approximation is really because
you are
um confusing average flow with extreme
flow
right so if if average flow contains the
same kind of information as extreme flow
then uh is okay you can just fit a a
classical linear
network and and you know you you would
sort of
expect to do okay right and that's so i
have some
graphs that sort of yeah so so we can
i mean i think proving this is very
important for extreme value theory
because then that will tell you like
where you should look for x where when
you should apply extreme values model
and when like a a max clean uh sorry a
classical bayesian network is enough
right so um so quantifying this i think
is is really uh
sort of important right um there's some
plots that
uh probably i skipped those parts are
are to support my
intuition of of this claim here right of
this this conjecture
that basically if your ex follows in
this regime then you can
and and you get extreme values uh from
this model
you can actually still learn it with a
linear bayesian network
and and it will it will do very well
yeah okay
uh okay so we have some results on
consistency
uh basically if you assume uh id noise
if the noise is
is light tail uh and and this uh z
the sources are gumbo which is a classic
uh distribution in extreme value theory
um
then you know our estimator with high
probability
uh can can recover the true network okay
so
uh it's it actually so without the noise
this theory is trivial with the noise it
took like
40 pages of calculations it's ridiculous
uh
yeah so yeah some some new techniques to
deal with that would also be helpful
um so there are applications beyond
hydrology so i
would point it here here's a paper by uh
gibson and uh and klupperberg
and and they they use sort of max linear
models to model
uh airline safety in lufthansa so this
is the problem of uh
when a plane sort of touches down uh
there's the possibility that due to a
variety of issues
it might run run beyond
the the runway and and stop outside of
the runway
that would be a very terrible disaster
and it turns out that you know it you
can model that
the possibility of that happened you can
model that with with a maximum
linear model and there there's been some
applications to to real airplanes right
okay so right so so in summary um i
should say
uh learning maths linear bayesian
networks um
is really uh the issues here if you want
to deal with data
is that is noisy and few right if you
just want to deal with theory
uh then it's an instance of can i learn
a two-layer reload networks
uh binary weights but just from outputs
right um so
there are lots of we get one algorithm
so there are lots of things we don't
know
right so there's better algorithms
definitely possible and
uh for reload networks i'm very
interested in questions of going beyond
two layers
right and it's i i think one possible
answer is by the work of veronica and
cording
who show that you know reload network
can be learned just by the
locus of of the of the graph where it's
not differentiable and so i think that
that would be a good place to look
okay all right well thank you thank you
very much
excellent thanks very much um they're uh
i guess we're right at the time that the
next talk is supposed to
start so if somebody has a quick
question i think it'd be great
to go ahead and ask and otherwise we're
good feel free to
share your screen and so forth so i have
a question
um in the hydrology application yes
don't you already know the tree from
looking at the river
yeah exactly so that's that's why it's a
baby version of the
of the true problem i want to resolve
right the true problem is the
contaminants
issue right and and for the contaminants
you don't
know right you have no idea how these
contaminants are transported
because contaminants are not simply
transported by
the river it could go into sewage and
see which could leak and
there could be many issues with it right
but so so the reason why this hidden
river problem is a benchmark is because
for any method you propose we have a
gold answer and so therefore we can just
validate your answer
against the goal nancy thanks
okay wait yeah sorry i didn't realize
that it's i thought it was until uh
45 but you know maybe i should have
finished a little bit earlier
sorry about that i don't know until 45
is perfect yeah i think a couple minutes
here and there
once friends it's not a big deal um
cool uh yeah i mean if there's any other
questions please definitely feel free to
ask
awesome well thanks for a really
interesting talk this is uh thank you
models